was nun herr scholz mit annalena
baerbock und armin laschet stehen ihre
konkurrenten ums kanzleramt jetzt fest
sie sind schon im september nominiert
worden haben aber bisher aus dem
vorsprung zeitlichen vorsprung nichts
machen können warum haben sie nicht mehr
zustimmung für die spd becken können die
immer noch zwischen 15 manchmal 17
prozent dümpelt wir wussten und deshalb
haben wir uns auch für eine frühe
nominierung entschieden dass wir eine
lange strecke hinter uns bringen müssen
damit wir am ende erfolgreich ankommen
können in der regierung im kanzleramt
und natürlich hatten wir auch von
vornherein überlegt dass dazu wichtig
ist dass irgendwann mal die cdu und die
grünen sagen wer erste kanzlerkandidaten
ihr kanzlerkandidat ist und dann ist das
rennen geöffnet und haben aus diesem
grunde bewusst entschieden unser
parteitag wo wir die kampagne beginnen
ist anfang mai also die aufholjagd
beginnt erst sagen sie nun haben wir das
erste mal einen dreikampf ums kanzleramt
und im grunde konzentriert sich
jedenfalls im moment die aufmerksamkeit
auf das rennen zwischen schwarz und grün
zwischen laschet und berbalk wie groß
ist für sie die gefahr dass sie so ein
bisschen aus dem fokus geraten bei aller
erfahrungen nicht so richtig ins spiel
kommen
gerade deshalb und wegen unserer
erfahrung haben wir entschieden dass wir
den parteitag anfang mai legen weil
daneben einmal alle gesagt haben mit wem
sie antreten wollen und außerdem die
blicke der bürgerinnen und bürger etwas
mehr auf die zukunft gerichtet sind die
korona pandemie ist hält uns alle immer
noch im griff aber wir kriegen schon das
gefühl dass der sommer besser werden
kann und dass dann die frage wie laufen
die 20er jahre
auch alle bewegt und dazu haben wir die
richtigen vorschläge deshalb glauben wir
dass wir auch vorne liegen können und
sie sagen dann fährt er stolz zog los
ich sage nicht es sind ja immer so
begriffe auf alle fälle ist wichtig eine
voraussetzung es schon geschafft die
cdu/csu wissen dass sie nicht über 30
prozent kommen so dass wir jetzt mit
einem sehr guten ergebnis deutlich in
den oberen 20 prozent auch die nächste
regierung führen kann obere 20 prozent
legen sie die latte hoch das merken wir
uns mal das 29 oder sind das 25
dass viele bürgerinnen und bürger
überzeugen dass sie die spd wählen die
haben jetzt ja auch plötzlich eine ganz
neue möglichkeit auf die
regierungsbildung einfluss zu nehmen im
verhältnis zu allen früheren jahren
keine partei wird die stärke der
früheren jahrzehnte erreichen ist wenn
viele parteien dem bundestag angehören
und mit seiner stimme kann man
entscheiden wer der nächste kanzler wird
die kernfrage ist das holz spricht der
senkrechtstart von frau berbalk und das
ist es ja die liegt jetzt bei 27 sie
sind immer noch bei 15 bis 17
spricht dieser senkrechtstart nicht
dafür dass die wälder jetzt wechseln
wollen veränderungen change wie die
amerikaner sagen und nicht erfahrung und
kontinuität wofür sie stehen ich stehe
vor allem dafür dass die zwanziger jahre
gut laufen denn die frage wie es uns
gehen wird in der zukunft die
entscheidet sich jetzt das ist nicht
eine sache die man in vier jahren wieder
in ordnung bringen kann falls man sich
jetzt geirrt hat wir müssen jetzt die
weichen dafür stellen dass wir nicht in
zehn 20 30 jahren dem wohlstand auf
anderen kontinenten traurig zuschauen
wir müssen jetzt die weichen dafür
stellen dass wir so große
herausforderung wie den
menschengemachten klimawandel bewältigen
das geht nur mit einer gemeinsamen
aktivität von wirtschaft forschung und
staatlichem handeln
und genau dafür haben wir die konzepte
die uns von den konservativen die
glauben alles geht von alleine und vom
auch den grünen ein bisschen
unterscheiden die die richtigen ziele
haben aber ab und zu muss man ja auch
mal eine stromleitung genehmigen wir
sprechen gleich über die konzepte herr
scholz aber trotzdem dass sie schon so
lange dabei sind dass sie so ein
bekanntes gesicht haben das heißt auch
dass sie für manches verantwortung
tragen was vielleicht schiefgegangen ist
also noch mal ist erfahrung nicht auch
eine last
es ist keine last und wenn man das
größte land europas in der europäischen
union führen will wenn man die
verantwortung für die zukunft europas
übernehmen möchte dann ist das als
deutscher regierungschef das tun will
was dazu notwendig ist dann ist
erfahrung auf alle fälle gut aber
erfahrung muss gepaart sein mit zwei
dingen die ich ganz wichtig finde den
richtigen herzen weil es ja um ein
gerechtes leben in der zukunft geht und
ganz unbedingt auch
einen plan für das was zu tun so da
machen wir es mal konkret sie wollen
zusammen mit ihrer umwelt ministerin die
auch von der spd kommt das
klimaschutzgesetz jetzt schnell
nachbessern auch nach dem urteil des
bundesverfassungsgerichts wollen da
sogar weiter gehen eigentlich als
karlsruhe fordert und das ist doch jetzt
genau die frage
neben ihnen die leute ab dass sie jetzt
einen so großen klimapolitischen ehrgeiz
haben sie hätten ja schon die waren in
der regierung sich viel vehementer
bemühen können ihre pläne durchzusetzen
man sieht ja jetzt dass der bei der
union auch in gewisser wille vorhanden
ist warum ist ihnen das nicht gelungen
ja haben uns vehement eingesetzt und
viele dinge auch tatsächlich
vorangebracht und der vorschlag dass man
sowie das bundesverfassungsgericht das
fordert auch 2040 ein klimaziel genau
errechnet und benennt stand in dem
gesetzesvorschlag von frau schulze der
umweltministerinnen drin
deshalb ist das genau die richtung die
wir richtig finden und das unterscheidet
uns auch von unseren konservativen
koalitionspartner
der nämlich eigentlich genau das immer
für eine mögliche politik gehalten hat
was das bundesverfassungsgericht jetzt
aufgespießt hat nämlich die dinge zu
vertagen und zu verschieben ich mach das
mal einem ganz konkreten beispiel
deutlich wir werden co2 neutralen nur
wirtschaften können wenn wir viel mehr
strom haben als heute
und es ist nicht gelungen gemeinsame
ziele zu vereinbaren über den strom
ausbau bis 2030 über den notwendigen
ausbau der erneuerbaren energien weil
das eben bei der union viel widerstand
ausgelöst hat wenn wir das jetzt anders
machen dann schafft das die grundlage
dafür dass basf seine konkreten pläne
für co2 neutrales wirtschaften umsetzen
kann die stahlunternehmen deutschland
die automobilunternehmen alle warten
jetzt darauf dass der staat seine
infrastruktur verantwortung wieder so
wahrnimmt wie das schon mal war in der
geschichte deutschland dafür haben wir
das richtige konzept und ich schon lange
daran gearbeitet dass das realität wird
aber auch sie mussten jetzt warten bis
quasi eine ohrfeige aus karlsruhe kommt
damit jetzt mal was vorangeht
ich bin ganz fest davon überzeugt dass
die entscheidung aus karlsruhe hilfreich
ist und die nahe bundestagswahl da wäre
einige beweglich die es bisher gab
waren wenn sie ihre frage ausdrücklich
das ist der unterschied die zukunft
werden wir nicht gewinnen dadurch dass
wir einfach darauf hoffen es geht von
alleine und wir werden sie auch nicht
gewinnen ohne tatkraft und den mut auch
etwas zu tun bei der infrastruktur in
deutschland das findet dann ja real
statt das ist nichts was man irgendwie
hübschen bildchen siebter werden
wirklich dinge gebaut wenn sie jetzt
sozusagen der bessere klimaschutz sein
wollen jedenfalls besser als die union
und wahrscheinlich auch besser als die
grünen besteht da nicht die gefahr dass
sie den grüninger den ball zuschieben
und dass die leute am ende dann doch
lieber das original wählen
wir haben sehr früh in diesem jahr
gesagt wie wir uns die zukunft
deutschlands vorstellen ich habe
zukunfts mission formuliert eine davon
ist richtigerweise der das aufhalten des
menschengemachten klimawandels das
andere ist moderne mobilität das dritte
ist die gigabit gesellschaft dass wir
dafür sorgen dass wir eine moderne
gesundheitswirtschaft in deutschland
haben
alles dinge wo auch sehr genau und
konkret beschrieben es wie das geht und
wo der unterschied zu der vergangenheit
ist dass wir dafür etwas tun müssen
deutschland darf nicht so gemütlich
bleiben dass es oft die dinge kommen von
selber wir müssen aktiv etwas dazu und
dann ist mit das ist mit zumutung
natürlich verbunden will noch mal
konkret nachfragen kohleausstieg darüber
wird ja jetzt dann diskutiert bleiben
sie dabei beim vereinbarten zeitpunkt 20
38 das bundesumweltamt fordert jetzt zum
beispiel 2030 wozu sind sie bereit sehen
sie da möglichkeiten oder sagen sie wie
die union jetzt heute wir sollten bei
dem versprechen bleiben weil es auch
sicherheit für unternehmen und
arbeitnehmer gibt da ist ein großer
gesellschaftlicher konsens gelungen und
wir haben entschieden aus der
kohleverstromung in deutschland
auszusteigen
wir haben ein absolutes enddatum gesetzt
dann wird man sehen wie die dinge voran
gehen aber aus meiner sicht gehört dazu
auch dass wir jetzt die 40 milliarden
euro einsetzen auf die wir uns
verständigt haben
um dafür zu sorgen dass in den regionen
die bisher für die energieversorgung
soll schon so wichtig waren gute
arbeitsplätze entstehen zum beispiel
auch im bereich der energiewirtschaft
wenn es jetzt um wasserstoff von
ähnliche dinge also sie sind nicht
bereit vorzuziehen beim thema kohle aus
die
herr scholz ein zweites thema ist das
was ich auf der strasse und der schiene
abspielt da geht es auch um die frage
der co2-emissionen
auch da haben die karlsruher richter
gesagt die pläne müssten konkreter
werden und wieder geht's und klimaschutz
oder jobs sind sie denn bereit ein datum
zu nennen was das thema abschaffung des
verbrennungsmotors angeht und da muss
auch hier der sozialdemokratie
arbeitsplatz immer an die erste stelle
rücken
beides ist gar kein gegensatz und das
ist vielleicht das was mal der eine oder
andere begreifen muss in dieser saison
aber jetzt schnell gehen
es muss jetzt sehr schnell gehen wir
haben milliarden investitionen der
automobilindustrie für elektrifizierte
mobilität auf den weg gebracht übrigens
mit der von der spd erfundenen
innovations- prämie für elektrifizierte
fahrzeuge dadurch ist jetzt der
durchbruch gelungen mitten in dieser
krone handel und ich bin sehr stolz
darauf dass wir genau dieses konzept
wirklichkeit haben werden lassen weil es
war der punkt an dem es jetzt geklappt
hat was aber das wird was ich ohne stars
fehlt jetzt es wird noch nicht ohne
schmerzen gehen sie müssen den leuten
sagen wann der umstieg auf den
verbrennungsmotor will ihr steht mal
sagen was als allererstes passieren muss
deutschland kann nicht sagen wir finden
dass schick dass jetzt die ganzen großen
deutschen automobilkonzerne milliarden
investieren elektrifizierte automobile
mobilität und dann sind wir so langsam
wenn es den ausbau angeht was die lade
infrastruktur betrifft sind wir so
langsam wenn es darum geht unser
stromnetz zu ertüchtigen damit möglichst
viele abends ihre autos in die steckdose
stecken können und das also damit
verbinden können und das sind glaube ich
die punkte die vergessen werden und
zudem zurückführen dass ich versucht
habe ihn eben zu sagen wir sind
eigentlich in so einer situation wie am
ende des neunzehnten jahrhunderts als
der große industrielle aufbruch
deutschlands gelangen zb im
eisenbahnwesen da sind bis heute
bekannte unternehmen entstand ihrem
lokomotiven gebaut und stahl hergestellt
aber der staat hat in kurzer zeit als
mein wesen das schienennetz zu stande
gebracht und dieses tempo brauchen wir
jetzt wenn es um glasfaserkabel geht um
da die infrastruktur wenn es um
wasserstoff netze geht um elektroden
diese und hydrologische und die
realisierung notwendig als würden sie
das gerade jetzt entdecken ich meine die
spd regiert seit vielen jahrzehnten und
sie sind dabei wieso jetzt plötzlich
dieser aufbruch und diese neuen
erkenntnisse
erstens sind sie nicht neu sondern sie
hatten schon die gelegenheit sogar in
ihrem fernsehsender das zu kommentieren
ist jetzt noch die gelegenheit gab das
schon umzusetzen was wir mit unserem
zukunftsprogramm anfang des jahres
vorgeschlagen haben aber zum zweiten ist
es auch so dass jetzt genau diese
zeitenwende auch begonnen hat in der das
realisiert werden muss und was natürlich
jetzt dringend notwendig ist damit das
klappt ist führung ist leadership und
ein sozialdemokrat kanzler ja
sozialdemokratischer kanzler aber was
bekommt man dann tatsächlich ein
sozialdemokrat würde man jetzt vermuten
kümmert sich vielleicht weniger als
allererstes ums klima dafür dass die
arbeitswelt dafür dafür dass die
arbeitswelt sicher ist dass die leute
gute jobs haben dass sie keine prekären
jobs haben dass die digitalisierung
trotzdem noch tariflöhne ermöglicht also
reicht da sozusagen der hinweis auf
einen mindestlohn von 12 euro müssten
sie nicht nicht tatsächlich sorgen dass
sie als sozialdemokrat diese prägung
nicht mehr erfüllen wir müssen uns genau
um diese frage kümmern erst mal wir
haben eben über industriepolitik über
wirtschaftspolitik über innovation
gesprochen und das thema klimawandel als
einen aspekt davon gesprochen aber da
geht es um arbeitsplätze und was die
frage betrifft die sie gesagt haben da
stimme ich ihnen vollständig zu deshalb
ist das erste wort das mit meiner
kandidatur mit meiner kanzlerschaft auch
verbunden sein soll respekt und
anerkennung
ich möchte dass wir den corona helden
und corona helden nicht nur beifall
klatschen dass die bessere löhne kriegen
bessere arbeitsbedingungen bessere
tarifverträge der mindestlohn von 12
euro na ja ungefähr der größenordnung
entspricht die präsident biden für die
usa vor schlägt mit 15 dollar
der ist ein bestandteil einer
umfassenden strategie in der wir eine
kehrtwende in deutschland einleiten wir
müssen und dürfen uns nicht nur als
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher
betrachten wir müssen auch die würde der
arbeit den respekt vor der arbeit wieder
stärker machen und das hat was mit
löhnen gehältern und sicheren
arbeitsverhältnissen zu tun
aber auch das will ich ausdrücklich
sagen mit einer umverteilung der
anerkennung
ich bin nicht bei denen die sich für
etwas besseres halten ich glaube wir
sind ein land das viel durchlässigkeit
organisieren muss das jeden möglich
machen muss dass man abitur machen
können und studieren kann
aber es muss auch klar sein dass die
handwerks meisterin in einer kleinen
stadt in deutschland genau richtig liegt
und nichts falsch macht sie wissen das
zu unserer sendung die satz ergänzung
gehört sie kennen das schon und wir
bitten sie jetzt mal wirklich kurz zu
sein ein halbsatz und sie ergänzen den
der erste hängt mit dem thema zusammen
kontinuität oderbruch mich als
bundeskanzler endgültig von der
schwarzen null zu verabschieden
entspricht der finanzplanung die cdu csu
und spd beschlossen haben und sie halte
daran fest wir werden in den nächsten
jahren ohne zusätzliche kredite unsere
aufgaben nicht erfüllen können das geben
sogar meine politischen wettbewerber zu
dass mit der spd und olaf scholz als
bundeskanzler die vermögenssteuer sicher
wieder eingeführt wird
das werde ich mit allem was mir
gesetzgeberisch möglich ist tun weil ich
dafür bin und was die schweiz kann
können wir dort schon auch dass wir
statt der mietpreis bremse bundesweit
einen echten mieten deckel brauchen wir
brauchen eine begrenzung der
mietpreisanstieg bundesweit wir haben
ein moratorium vorgeschlagen dass den
mieten anstieg begrenzt und das ist auch
genau der richtige weg zusammen mit
begrenzung bei neuvermietung und
zusammen mit sehr viel wohnungsbau dem
man nach oben zusätzlich braucht die
kanzlerschaft auf zwei amtszeiten zu
begrenzen
finde ich aus meiner perspektive eine
ziemlich gute idee aber ob das jetzt für
ganz deutschland gelten muss weiß ich
nicht also ich jedenfalls glaube dass es
schon zwei amtszeiten sein sollten er
schoss bitte nur ein halbsatz als
vizekanzler und finanzminister unter
annalena baerbock zu dienen
ich will kanzler werden den wahlkreis
potsdam in denen sie beide antreten
gegen annalena baerbock zu gewinnen ist
mein ziel und ich treffe unglaublich
viele bürger hamburger habe das gute
gefühl das klappt doch nicht mitten im
wahlkampf vor zwei
untersuchungsausschüssen rechtfertigen
zu müssen ist nicht schön aber gehört
zur demokratie dazu und ist völlig in
ordnung
hätten sie sich bei wirecard wo sie ja
im grunde sagen ich habe mir nichts
vorzuwerfen ich werde die finanzaufsicht
jetzt aber verbessern nicht zumindest
mal entschuldigen müssen oder können
selbst wenn sie sich nichts vorzuwerfen
haben na ja das ist ja da auch
rausgekommen dass alle entlang der
bisherigen gesetze gehandelt haben beim
bundesministerium und auch der aufsicht
und dass die gesetze aber nicht
ausreichend sind und wir auch die
aufsichtsbehörden mit neuen
möglichkeiten und mitteln ausstatten das
anders verstanden sie sagen ich bin
nicht das problem ich liefere die lösung
dass er verstanden ich besser vor
ja ich wäre ihnen ja zu aber meine das
stellt mich nicht zufrieden meine frage
war ob sie sich nicht mal bei den bei
den vielen kleinanlegern die die es auch
gab einfach hätten entschuldigen ist
dafür
ich finde das ganz bedrückendes wie
viele da ihr geld verloren haben das ist
wirklich schlimm
und deshalb müssen wir auch das jetzt
alles durchsetzen dass wir auf den weg
gebracht haben
ich will das ausdrücklich noch mal sagen
ohne die öffentliche aufmerksamkeit wäre
der druck der lobbyisten so groß gewesen
dass ich nicht weiß ob ich genügend
bündnispartner für diese jetzt sehr
weitreichenden reform gefunden hätte
aber jetzt haben wir das schon hin
gekriegt und das ist wirklich ein gutes
zeichen keine entschuldigung schneller
als geplant
scholz soll am kommenden freitag wollen
sie den geimpften die freiheitsrechte
zurückgeben bund und länder
sie drücken da auch aufs tempo mit der
spd das wetter am ende die älteren
wieder begünstigen gegenüber den
jüngeren was haben sie eigentlich den
jüngeren als dank für ihre solidarität
anzubieten können sie sagen bis wann
studierende zum beispiel geimpft sein
denn erstens dass im camper nimmt gerade
dramatisch zu dafür habe ich mich sehr
eingesetzt dass das jetzt gelingt und
wir sind schon sehr sehr weit gekommen
das geht jetzt mit millionen schritten
weiter nach vorne und deshalb werden
auch die jüngeren und die studierenden
drankommen aber was mir mindestens so
wichtig ist dass wir was für die tun
diese woche werden wir ein aufholen
paket von zwei milliarden für kinder und
jugendliche auf den weg bringen wo es
nicht nur ums nachholen von lern
rückständen geht sondern auch um
freizeit möglichkeiten um auch die
freundschaften wieder zu aktivieren die
jetzt durch all die beschränkungen
gefährdet worden sind und das ist mir
sehr sehr wichtig gerade weil es
stadtteile und gegnern in deutschland
gibt wo die wohn und lebensverhältnisse
so beengt sind dass man nicht einfach
ausweichen kann auf andere möglichkeiten
sich zuerst jetzt gibt es ein
aufholprozess wetters zu den punkten
gehören wo sie auch mal sagen müssen
dann muss uns tatsächlich verziehen
werden dass sie die die schüler die
kinder die jugendlichen zu wenig im
blick hatten als man das regierte die
immer im blick und deshalb habe ich mich
für etwas eingesetzt und zwar auch
einige das nicht mehr so laut gesagt
haben die das auch mal gesprochen haben
dass wir sagen wir schließen schulen und
kitas zuletzt und öffnen sie zuerst das
ist jetzt auch in allen gesetzen die
regelung geworden wir haben das testen
dort durchgesetzt werden milliarden
eingesetzt für die digitalisierung aus
bundesmitteln damit dass vorangebracht
wird und wir merken dass das natürlich
alles nicht mit dem tempo voran geht wie
man sich das für deutschland wünschen
muss deshalb ist auch mein ganz ganz
klarer wille dass wir jetzt nicht nach
der pandemie aufhören sondern dass all
die dinge die wir da an bewegung gesetzt
haben einschließlich einer
grundgesetzänderung damit wir mehr für
schulen aus bundesmitteln tun können
dass die auch in den nächsten jahren
fortgeführt werden sie sagen sie drücken
aufs tempo das impfen nimmt zu ganz kurz
haben sie schon sommerurlaub gebucht und
würden sie das den zuschauern zu schauen
jetzt empfehlen können man muss
vorsichtig sein ich habe auch eine idee
wo ich im sommer im urlaub hinfahre in
deutschland aber natürlich bin ich
abhängig von der entwicklung wie alle
anderen deshalb eine persönliche haltung
wenn wir jetzt weiter vorankommen wenn
die infektionszahlen sich so
weiterentwickeln dass gegenwärtig sich
abzeichnet wenn wir es hinbekommen dass
die noch weiter runter gehen wenn das
impfen weiter fortgeschritten ist dann
sollten wir irgendwann zum ende dieses
monats eine klare ansage darüber machen
nicht so wie einige das befürchten man
sagt dann geht es los mit dem urlaub und
zwei wochen später wird es zurück
gerufen sondern wir sagen klar das geht
und ich hoffe dass das klappt weil wir
dürfen hier nicht eine rhetorik des
ewigen winters entfalten all die
maßnahmen die wir machen die ihm doch
dazu dass wir ab dem sommer wieder etwas
mehr hoffnung schöpfen können sagt der
bundesfinanzminister und kanzlerkandidat
der spd vielen dank olaf scholz und
vielen dank für ihr interesse
tschüss aus berlin